behind the scenes
the euro federalists are busy with the
change european treaties to work towards 1
peaceful States of Europe
but people at home want this
we asked the renowned you know research
and guess what
only 20% of the Dutch want
more powers to the EU
and if you don't believe this research from ianno
shows that 1 other search from yxos
this month that only 12% are in favor of it
Dutch do not want EU taxes
want countries to keep their own pants financially
decide for yourself from which countries it allows asylum seekers
and certainly don't want any
digital euro
the Dutch want a large majority
the common market
like that under the eeg once worked so well
chairman
the EU must be about our economic security
NATO for military security
and the Member States themselves are about their sovereignty
the federalists sometimes don't want to hear these figures
but it is the democratic reality